North Korea isn't known for treating
foreigners with respect
remember otto warmbier there's also that
ongoing threat of nuclear war so it took
a lot of people by surprise when they
heard nbc's top anchor Lester Holt
making a point to credit the country for
its kind treatment during his recent
visit we arrived in North Korea on
Saturday we flew the North Korean state
airline it's about an hour and a half
flight from Beijing we have been treated
with respect here we have been invited
and our guests of the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs we stayed in a
guesthouse outside feeling yang last
night and then made our way to this ski
resort to get a look at a part of North
Korea that most Americans don't see and
certainly a part they would like us to
see all right Dana do you think lessor
whole it realizes he's handing the North
Koreans a propaganda victory yeah I do
because I've watched a couple of these
reports and in each report he does have
a little bit of a caveat and a little
bit like like we get the joke here but I
think that this video and these
invitations are not meant for us this is
meant for internal propaganda
brainwashing so that the leader the Dear
Leader can show all the people there
that live in North Korea just how
respected the North Koreans are just how
wonderful their country is meanwhile
most the country is starving and it is
absolutely outrageous
on in the Weekly Standard one of your
favorites Ethan emphasized description
now thanks yeah thank you
Ethan Epstein writes a piece today
that's it's called 12 times the media
offered a rare glimpse into North Korea
in just the last several years so
obviously we are being used if you were
Lester Pretender Lester I am would you
accept the invitation or would you say
no way I don't know you know imagine if
Fox and Friends did a week of shows in
North Korea cooking with friends would
be literal be like the casserole looks
familiar
I like it what he says he says they
showed us part of North Korea that we
don't see we don't see any part of North
Korea we only see what they let us see
this is what's very common among
communist leaders they did this
constantly with Hollywood celebrities
they would invite the Hollywood
celebrities would go to Cuba they go to
USSR Venezuela they would turn
hapless naive suckers like Sean Penn
into fellow traveling mouthpieces and
because you know why they would treat
you well they get to booze that get you
women they do all sorts of stuff that's
right but the thing is there's three
there's some interesting things that
could happen during this they could be
taken hostage what do we do then
the US has probably cannot exercise a
military option knowing that those
people are there or they could infect
them with some kind of biological agent
and sent them back to the United States
which is you know possible did you slay
awake at night thinking about this I
think I bet it all the time Kimberly
what do you think about that I mean we
just asked to go to the Super Bowl no
wait a second
cuz you know last time you went they
were like 10 kg yeah it was good look so
Lester Holt has an opportunity to go
there I get it as a journalist I don't
begrudge him the opportunity but
nevertheless I think some of the
criticisms you know is fair and when you
actually look at the facts the
circumstance is the evidence the Intel
coming out of North Korea you see it is
a barbaric road Virginie where people
are being starved his army is starving
there now still being told to steal food
from starving farmers he is on a charm
campaign offensive for the Olympics to
try to prove that there's something
other than what they are and that's why
he's sending dancers and this and that
over to the Olympics to see so let not
your mind to be fooled right and part of
the charm offensive they're having the
North Korean athletes train with South
Korean athletes and I think the Dear
Leader's spent about thirty five million
dollars on this fancy ski resort so it's
all part of the propaganda yeah
absolutely and you the the the key
political point is here you will have
twenty two North Korean athletes
marching with the South Korean
delegation right into the Olympics and
this is a real show of unity until you
have moon jae-in who's the president of
South Korea agreeing to this kind of
daytime it's not necessarily in the
interest of the United States as we try
to put pressure on North Korea to hold
back in terms of our nuclear weapons and
the sanctions regime as Kimberly just
said all of that now starts to fall and
be uncertain and I think part of it is
to have Americans come in they had vice
come in we've had see others go in
Lester Howe
the idea is to you know humanize them
soften them up here they are at the ski
resort but it's just again this is
propaganda and you just got to see it
for what it is